SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE I'M GOING TO MAKE
SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO
EXPLAIN THE PROCESSES WE'VE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THIS PROCESS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WHILE
I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR THOSE
WHO MAY BE TUNING IN FOR THE
FIRST TIME. I'M GOING TO COVER
SOME OF THE TECHNICAL SIDE OF
THINGS FOR THE DAY. IN RESPONSE
TO THE KOBE NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING.
AND WE'VE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW. THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO THIS HEARING.
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. SO FOR THE
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. I'M GONNA ANNOUNCE IT
NOW AND AGAIN BEFORE WE TURN TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS- AND THAT
PORTION OF THE AGENDA. SO GET
READY WITH YOUR PENS EVERYONE
IF YOU'RE TUNING IN. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER FOR THOSE OF
YOU WISHING TO WRITE IT DOWN.
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO
SIX EIGHT ONE EIGHT NINE. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE EIGHT NINE AND YOU NEED AN
ACCESS CODE WHICH IS. TWO EIGHT
SEVEN SIX ZERO FIVE NINE. ONE
MORE TIME. TWO EIGHT SEVEN SIX
ZERO FIVE NINE IS OUR ACCESS
CODE. WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY WILL
OPEN YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
SO WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARING AND IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW ONLINE
TOOL SO AGAIN LET'S BE PATIENT
SO EVERYONE CAN BE HEARD. ALSO
ON BEHALF OF OUR COURT REPORTER
I'M GOING TO ASK ALL SPEAKERS
MY COLLEAGUES AND WITNESSES A
LIKE TO SPEAK SLOWLY AND
CLEARLY. I BEFORE WE- BEGIN
TODAY'S AGENDA WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. OF OUR VICE
CHAIR WILL BE A LITTLE BIT LATE
TODAY. AND WILL ACCOMMODATE
WHEN SHE ARRIVES- SO THAT SHE
HAS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
OUR- A CONFEREES- SHE'LL BE
ABLE TO DO THAT BUT SHE WILL BE
HERE TODAY I WANT TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT. SO ARE A
REMINDER TO MY COLLEAGUES
YOU'LL NEED TO TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONE FOR ROLL CALL AND
EVERY TIME THAT WE VOTE. SO
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY WILL
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL- I OR
PRESENT. EURO PRESENT. CAN
LONGER HERE. KAMLAGER HERE
LAYARD HERE THEY'RE HERE BATES
ATKINS. YOUR ATKINS HERE. OUR
FIRST ART LET'S GO AHEAD AND
TAKE UP ITEM TO- AGAIN WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE VICE
CHAIR WHEN SHE ARRIVES AND THAT
WOULD BE ITEM TO THE
RATIFICATION OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON THE CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE WILL BE COMPOSED
OF FIVE MEMBERS. AND THE
APPOINTMENTS OF THE SENATOR
BECKER IS CHAIR SENATORS DOLLY
GONZALEZ MEN AND STERN TO FILL
ALL VACANCIES REMOVE THE
RATIFICATION THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. GROVE FIVE. OH
FIVE KAMLAGER. HI AND WEBER I
LAYERED HI THERE HI. EIGHT
ATKINS. I HAVE CONCERNS AND WE
WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR OUR
VICE CHAIR WHEN SHE ARRIVES. SO
NOW WE'RE GOING TO TURN AND YOU
WILL REMEMBER A REMIND ME MADAM
SECRETARY BECAUSE I ALWAYS
FORGET. THAT I KNOW THAT YOU
WILL. I WE WILL TURN TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR AT THAT IS ITEMS ONE
A. AND ONE B. TWO APPOINTMENTS
TO THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BOARD OF GOVERNORS.
THEY ARE MISS JENNIFER L. PERRY
AND MISTER BLOSS VIA VIA LOBOS-
AND THEY ARE WITH US ON THE
SCREEN WAITING PATIENTLY THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
OUT WE WILL TAKE UP OUR
INTRODUCTIONS IN ORDER THAT I
STATED- WHICH IS THE ORDER THE
FILE BEGINNING WITH MISS PERRY
AND THEN MR VIA LOBOS. AND
AFTER BOTH OF YOU HAVE GIVEN
YOUR- INTRODUCTIONS AND OPENING
COMMENTS I'LL GO TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. SO MISS PERRY WE WILL
BEGIN WITH YOU AND IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE ANYONE THAT'S
WITH YOU OR THAT YOU WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THEN MAKE YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS PLEASE GO
RIGHT AHEAD WELCOME. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS- MY
NAME IS JENNIFER L. PERRY. AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY- TO BE HERE
TODAY- AS I LOOK BACK. ON THE
PROCESS OF BEING RECONFIRMED TO
AT TO THIS ROLE IT'S REALLY
BEEN A WONDERFUL WAY TO LOOK
BACK AND SEE IF THE ROAD. THE
VERY PROFOUND ROAD THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE
TRAVELED OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS- AND CERTAINLY THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE. BUT
WHAT I'VE SEEN IS- A LOT OF
VISIONARY LEADERSHIP- ON THE
PART OF THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
IT IS REALLY REWORKING AND
RETHINKING AND REDIRECTING THE
SYSTEM. SO THAT IT MORE FULLY
MEETS THE NEEDS OF THAT ONE
POINT TWO MILLION STUDENTS THAT
WE SERVE AND IT IS PAN AND
ENERGETIC. AND. A CHALLENGING
ROLE BUT I- THE VISION- AND
LITERALLY THE VISION FOR
SUCCESS HAS BEEN. IS ONE THAT.
BEST AND WILL BEST SERVE OUR
STUDENTS FOR THE YEARS TO COME
IT'S RECOGNIZED THAT THE
CHANGES IN THE STATE THE
CHANGES IN THE DEMOGRAPHICS AND
THE CHANGES IN THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS. AND REALLY SORT OF
REFRAME THE WHOLE- SO THAT
STUDENTS ARE LOOKED AT IN A
HOLISTIC MANNER MANNER SORRY
AND IN A WAY- THAT WILL REALLY
ENSURE THEIR EDUCATIONAL
SUCCESS- IN THE NOT TO TAKE UP
TOO MUCH TIME BUT THE- ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT'S BEEN GREAT
ABOUT THIS PROCESS IS. IT'S
ALSO OCCASION FOR ME TO TAKE A
LOOK BACK AND REALISE- WHAT
EXTRAORDINARY CULMINATION OF
PUBLIC SERVICE WORK THAT I'VE
DONE IN THE PAST THIS IS- I
WORKED AT A HEAD START I WORK
CURRENTLY WITH YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE. AND BEING ABLE TO BE PART
OF A SYSTEM THAT REALLY
RECOGNIZE THE RESILIENCE
RECOGNIZE THE RESILIENCE AND
THE HOPE AND THE POTENTIAL IN
EVERY SINGLE USE AN ADULT IN
CALIFORNIA- IS. SOMETHING THAT
I'M REALLY PROUD TO BE A PART
OF IT IT SEEMS. FROM MY
STANDPOINT TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
WORK THAT I DO SORT OF WRIT
LARGE- IN PARTICULAR AS- THERE
ARE NOW ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND
FOSTER YOUTH IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM UP FROM YEARS
PAST AND I'VE SEEN FIRST. HOW
IMPACTFUL THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE FOR THOSE USE AND
HOW THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
THEIR GATEWAY TO A BETTER
FUTURE AND HAVE PROVIDED
SUPPORT SYSTEMS. AND AN OPEN
DOOR POLICY- THAT IS REALLY
GOING TO MAKE A SIGNIFICANT.
DIFFERENCE FOR THE ISSUES. AND
I'VE SEEN IT FIRST HAND- OUR
DAUGHTER WHO WE ADOPTED FROM
FOSTER CARE- WAS A STUDENT AT
SANTA MONICA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND USED TO TRANSFER TO UC
DAVIS SO- I SEE IT EVERY DAY IN
THE WORK THAT I DO IN FIRSTHAND
SO AGAIN. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND- I AM HONORED
TO BE ABLE TO SERVE- THE
STUDENTS AND THE ADULTS OF THE
STATE AND THE IN THE STATE IN
SUCH A MANNER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THOSE OPENING
COMMENTS- MISTER VIA LOBOS DO
YOU WANT TO ALSO. ACKNOWLEDGE
ANYONE THAT YOU WOULD LIKE AND
MAKE SOME OPENING COMMENTS
WELCOME. I HEAR MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES- MY
NAME IS DR BOBBY A LITTLE.
HERE'S A PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE
TODAY ARE LIKELY TELL YOU JUST
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT- AFTER
SERVING IN THE MARINE CORPS FOR
YEARS. I HAD A VERY IMPORTANT
DECISION TO MAKE AND THAT WAS
EITHER REINVEST. OR LEAVE THE
MILITARY GO BACK TO SCHOOL-
HOWEVER AFTER FOUR YEARS IN THE
SERVICE OF NOT SURE COLLEGE IN
THE RIGHT PLACE FOR ME. AND
THAT IS WHEN A FRIEND MENTIONED
ON THE CITY COLLEGE AND
APPARATUS WORK WITH THAT I
REALIZED LBCC WILL GET A
PERFECT PLACE FOR ME TO BEGIN
MY ACADEMIC CAREER- I HAVE
SINCE I WAS A CAREER WORKING
WITH VETERANS AND MILITARY
FAMILIES. AND EVERY PRODUCT OF
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM I
CAN HONESTLY SAY. I WOULD NOT
BE WHERE I AM TODAY WITHOUT THE
SUPPORT AND EDUCATION I
RECEIVED. AS A STUDENT
BACKGROUND. MOSTLY CITY
COLLEGE- SERVING ON THE BOARD
OF GOVERNORS IS AN HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE AND I THINK YOU'RE
VERY SERIOUSLY. AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE MY BEST
REPRESENTING OUR STUDENT
VETERANS AND MILITARY FAMILIES
BROTHERS TWO. AND I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO MEET WITH THIS AFTERNOON
AFTER THE AFTER THE HEARING
FLETCHER INSPECTIONS YEAH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND DR
PLEASE FORGIVE ME FOR ALL OF
FOR MISSING YOUR TITLEI KNOW
THAT. IT WAS WELL EARNED SO. MY
APOLOGIES- SENATOR LAYER- GO
AHEAD AND START WITH YOU IF YOU
ARE PREPARE. I AM THANK YOU-
CHAIR. IN AND LET ME JUST SAY I
KNOW THESE TO THIS HEARING WAS
POSTPONED AND- I MET WITH YOU
NUMBER FOUR WEEKS AGO. AND IT
WAS RELLY HELPFUL MEETING WITH
BOTH OF YOU AND I'M REALLY
COMFORTABLE BUT I THOUGHT I'D
PUT ONE QUESTION JUST SORT OF
TO EACH OF YOU OUT OF THE
MEETING AND- AND TO JENNIFER
PERRY. OF THIS IS A
REAPPOINTMENT FOR YOU AND YOUR
FORTY SERVE SIX YEARS ON THE
BOARD AND WE TALKED ABOUT. WHAT
YOU'VE LEARNED OVER SIX YEARS
AND HOW IT'S GOING TO HONE IN
ON YOUR FOCUS FOR THE NEXT TERM
AND I THOUGHT I'D GIVE YOU A
CHANCE TO. TO SPEAK TO THAT AND
PUBLIC HOW WOULD YOU TALK ABOUT
WHAT YOU'VE LEARNED DURING YOUR
SERVICE AND HOW IT'S GOING TO
FOCUS YOU GOING FULL. THANK YOU
SENATOR AND IT WAS IT WAS A
PLEASURE TO MEET WITH YOU AS A-
COUPLE WEEKS AGO WHATEVER IT
WHENEVER IT WAS- AND THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION I MEAN. THE
TRUTH IS YOU KNOW THE EARLY
PART OF THE SIX YEARS WAS A
HUGE LEARNING CURVE. AND WE
THINK THE GLASS AND I HAVE
DISCUSSED THIS I MEAN THE
SYSTEM AS YOU KNOW. COMPLEX AND
INTRICATE AND MULTI FACETED SO-
PART OF. REALLY SOME OF THE
GREAT PRO THAT TAKE AWAY FROM
THAT FOR SIX YEARS. I
UNDERSTAND THE SYSTEM. SO MUCH
BETTER- AND- THAT WILL. SERVE
ME WELL IN TERMS OF- LOOKING
FORWARD- TO WHAT I WANT TO
FOCUS ON AS- AS I THINK I'VE
MENTIONED. TO YOU BEFORE I. ONE
PROUD OF AND LUCKY ENOUGH TO
SERVE. ON THE BOARD AT THE TIME
WHEN WE ARE CREATING THE VISION
FOR SUCCESS. AND IMPLEMENTING-
SORT OF OUR D. III STRUCTURE
AND PRIORITIES FOR THE YEARS TO
COME. SO THOSE ARE. ON THEIR
WAY BUT THERE'S STILL A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK TO BE
DONE THERE ALREADY WAS
OBVIOUSLY THE PANDEMIC. HAS
SLOWED DOWN THE PROGRESS- OF
SOME OF THE BIG INITIATIVES
THAT WE'VE BUT WE'VE
UNDERTAKEN. BUT I THINK YOU
KNOW SR VICE CHANCELLOR AS YOU
GONZALEZ SAID TO US IN A RECENT
MEMO WE STILL NEED TO KEEP
LASER FOCUSED ON. OUR STUDENTS
FROM IN SPITE OF ALL THAT I
THINK. SO FAR- WE ARE DOING A
PRETTY GOOD JOB OF THAT- GIVEN
GIVEN EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING
ON- FROM A PERSONAL STANDPOINT-
I WOULD I MY FOCUS REALLY WILL
CONTINUE TO BE. THOSE FORTY
SOME ODD THOUSAND YEARS IN
FOSTER. CARE THAT. OUR
ATTENDING OR CAN YOU OLLEGE.
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD WORK THAT
CAN BE DONE- HAS BEEN DONE. HEY
WE NEED A- OUR PROGRAMS LIKE
NEXT UP- TO. DROP THE AGE FOR
ELIGIBILITY TO EXPAND THE
PROGRAM TO MORE CAMPUSES. WE
NEED TO EXPAND OUR INCREASE OUR
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THOSE
FOSTER USE BECAUSE- WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO WELCOME THEM
TO. MAKE SURE IT'S OKAY TO BE
KNOWN AS OUR OUR- VERY LUCKY-
IN OUR VICE CHANCELLOR TO HAVE-
A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND WE
HAVE. COMING ON TO THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS A YOUNG MAN WHO'S
SUPPOSED TO BE. WHO BY ALL
ACCOUNTS IS VERY DYNAMIC AND-
HE'S MENTIONED AND I THINK HE'S
RIGHT NOW PART OF OUR ROLE IS
TO- IS TO. ACTUALLY INCREASE
COMMUNICATION PROFESSION YOU SO
THAT THEY FEEL COMFORTABLE
ACCESSING THE STUDENTS THAT WE
ARE WE ARE. JUST STARTING WITH
THE- THE SERVICES THAT WE HAVE
BEEN THERE FOR THEM- SO. I
THINK THAT LOOKING FOR WILL BE
A BIG PART OF MY ROLE AND ALSO.
AS I MENTIONED TO YOU- ENSURING
THAT CALIBRATE- WHICH HAS
REGAINED ITS FOOTING- TO A
GREAT DEGREE. CONTINUES ON THAT
COURSE NOT BECAUSE I THINK IT
HAS A LOT TO. OFFER THAT THE
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA. I THANK
YOU FOR THAT TO A RESPONSE I
APPRECIATED AND- AND YOU DID
MENTION A NUMBER OF THINGS
INCLUDING CAL BRIGHT THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT A DURING THE
SESSION. AND I KNOW WE ALSO
TALKED ABOUT THE FUNDING
FORMULA AND THE FACT THAT
THAT'S GOING TO NEED TO BE.
DEALT WITH GIVEN SOME OF THE
COLLEGES THAT ARE IN HOLD
HARMLESS STAGE IN THAT WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO WORK ON THAT
GOING FORWARD NOT APPRECIATED
BOTH OF YOUR COMMENTS ON THAT.
AND FOR DOCTOR OF VIA LOBOS.
JUST AS AS MISS PERRY TALKED
ABOUT HER EXPERIENCE. WITH
FOSTER CARE BEING A PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE THAT SHE BRINGS TO.
THE BOARD WHEN WE TALKED. YOUR
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AS A
VETERAN AND VETERANS PROGRAMS.
I SEEM LIKE IT WAS- SOMETHING
THAT. ARE YOU BROUGHT TO THE
BOARD IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF
VETERANS THAT ARE IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. AND I
DID ENJOY OUR BRIEF MOMENT
WHERE YOU TALKED ABOUT PEOPLE
WITH NO GRADES BEING CHALLENGED
IN GETTING VA BENEFITS. YOU
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND YOU WERE
TALKING TO THE ONE MEMBER OF
THE COMMITTEE. THAT HAS A FOUR
YEAR COLLEGE DEGREE WITHOUT
GETTING A SINGLE LETTER GRADE.
IT AND YOU WALKED RIGHT INTO
THAT AND YOU WERE VERY. YOU HAD
UPON WHEN YOU REALIZE THAT SO-
WHAT'S YOUR- TALK ABOUT YORK'S.
AS A VETERAN AND WITH VETERANS
PROGRAMS AND WHAT THAT PROMPTS
YOU TO DO AS A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE- GOVERNOR. YES SIR R.
WILL FIRST AND FOREMOST- I CAN
TELL YOU THAT- OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE DOING INCREDIBLE
JOB WORKING WITH OUR VETERANS
AND MILITARY FAMILIES. WHEN I
FIRST STARTED AT LONG BEACH
CITY COLLEGE IN SPRING TWO
THOUSAND FOUR- BETTER RESOURCE
CENTERS FOR NOT A- WE'RE NOT A
BANK PERCENT. WE HAD NO BUDGET
RESOURCE CENTERS ON CAMPUS AT
THE TIME- THOSE DID NOT COME
UNTIL WAY AFTER- BUT I WAS
LUCKY ENOUGH AND BLESSED TO BE
ABLE TO SEE THEM GET BALLS AND-
TRYING TO WHAT THEY ARE TODAY.
WHICH IF THE SPACE FOR VETERANS
AND MILITARY FAMILIES REALLY
GET TOGETHER AND- TALK TO
SOMEONE ABOUT THE BENEFITS OF
FIVE FOR THE BENEFITS AND YOU
KNOW THEY'RE VETERANS AND
MILITARY. FAMILY MEMBERS ARE IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE- AS A
VETERAN COMMUNITY COLLEGE THAT
THE MARKETS THAT MIGHT BENEFIT-
ALLOWED ME TO USE. BACK TO
SCHOOL- THIS THAT I RECEIVE AT
THE- COLLEGE- REALLY.
INFLUENCED MY CAREER PATH-
BECAUSE I WAS ABLE TO NEEDS-
HUNDREDS. OF VETERANS AND MANY
OF THEM WERE ACTUALLY
STRUGGLING WITH MENTAL HEALTH
AND HOUSING YOU CHOOSE. AND
THAT IS WHAT SPARKED MY
INTEREST IN THE BACK FROM SPACE
TO WORK WITH VETERANS AND-
MILITARY FAMILIES IN THE FIRST
PLACE- THAT IS YOU KNOW I COULD
WALK INTO A CAREER WORKING WITH
SECONDS AND ALL HER FAMILY- BUT
IT ALSO HAS- OPENED MY EYES TO
SOME OF THE- IT WILL CHALLENGES
OUR VETERANS ARE FACING- IN THE
SYSTEM. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
VETERANS AND MILITARY FAMILIES
WITH STRUGGLING WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES HOUSING ISSUES-
EMPLOYMENT ISSUE. AND MICHAEL-
FOR THE NEXT THAT WE WANTED TO.
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON WORKING
FLAT- NEEDED ORGANIZATIONS AND
THE BATHROOMS ARE CENTERS OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO. MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES FOR ACTION
OUR FAMILY. AS THEY ARE NEEDED-
MICHAEL HAS ALWAYS CHANGE YOU.
ARE ENGAGED WITH A BACK AND
POPULATION. AND TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES. THE
FOURTEENTH- NEEDS BECOME A
CRISIS ARE FORTUNATELY WHAT
I'VE SEEN. THROUGHOUT MY CAREER
SEVERAL TIMES IN FACT WE- START
TO ENGAGE A POPULATION. IN THE
STATE BACKED UP FOR EXAMPLE
ONCE THEY ARE PRICES AND
MICHAEL DOLLARS THANK YOU FOR
ACTIVE AND IDENTIFY THOSE
NEEDS- I HAD A TIME IN REALLY
BE MORE PROACTIVE AND- ADDRESS
THOSE MOVE BEFORE THEY GET TO A
POINT WHERE- NOW THEY CRISIS
MODE- THAT'S WHY I'M VERY
THANKFUL. TO HAVE BEEN
REAPPOINTED TO THE BOARD- I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE MET- BAKER
RESOURCE CENTERS AND- VETERANS
AND MILITARY FAMILIES WATER
SYSTEM AND- THE FIFTEENTH RIGHT
THAT APPOINTMENT CHALLENGES
YOU'RE FACING. AND ADDRESS.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE APPRECIATE
BOTH YOUR COMMENTS LOOK FORWARD
SUPPORT YOU BOTH. THANK YOU
SENATOR- LET ME ASK MA'AM SURE
YOU READ OR DO YOU ME TO GIVE
YOU A MORE TO. I AM A GOOD
BECAUSE. I AM I AM ON NOT YET
YOU ARE. I'M I'M A LITTLE
DISCOUNT GUYS PAULA EYES I JUST
FROM SO I HAVE TO GO BACK SO I
KNEW IN. COLUMN BUT I WANTED TO
SHARE MINE WITH YOU INITIALLY I
THINK THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM IS PROBABLY ONE OF THE
BEST THINGS CALIFORNIA'S DONE
AN EXPANDING IT IS THE PROVIDED
ME AN INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY.
HI TO NOT TO LOSE A YEAR OF
COLLEGE MAKING MY PARENTS VERY
HAPPY WHEN I WAS ABLE TO GO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND PICK UP A
SEMESTER BECAUSE I'D BE AND-
OUT OF THE COUNTRY ARE. DOING
AS A FOREIGN NOT EXCHANGE
STUDENT SO THAT WAS GREAT AND
THEN WHEN I RETURNED I WAS ABLE
TO PICK UP SOME ADDITIONAL-
ADDITIONAL UNITS ALSO TO MOVE
FORWARD IN IN MY CAREER AS A
SOCIAL WORKER SO. IT'S JUST
GREAT AND NOW LOOKING AT YOUR
RESUMES AND HEARING. ACTUALLY
YOUR RESUME AS AN ANODE KNOWING
THE TIME THAT YOU MISS PERRY.
AND YOU DOCTOR VIA LOBOS HI I
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IS OBVIOUSLY
SOMETHING THAT. I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF AND SUPPORTIVE OF
YOU THE QUESTIONS I WAS GOING
TO. ASK WERE ABOUT THE FOSTER
YOUTH AND ALSO ABOUT THE
VETERANS. RESOURCE CENTER IN
WHAT'S GOING ON THERE I KNOW ON
MY COMMUNITY COLLEGE SAID ABOUT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. IN SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY HAS BEEN VERY
INVOLVED. I SEE YOU NODDING
YOUR HEAD SO I. DIDN'T BE AN
AGRI AND ALSO ON THE WORK FORCE
ON INVESTMENT THE WORK FORCE OF
COLLEGE. OR THE WORKFORCE.
SKEWS THE WORK FORCE OF. AGENDA
THAT THEY HAVE THAT THE CLASSES
EXCUSE ME TO HELP WITHOUT
CERTAINLY VERY IMPORTANT FOR
BOTH OF OUR FOSTER YOUTH AND
OUR VETERANS SO THAT WOULD I
COULD LET YOU OFF THE HOOK AND
NOT ASK ANY QUESTIONS BECAUSE
THEY WERE ASKED SPECIFICALLY
THAT I WAS VERY INTERESTED IN
THAT BECAUSE I KNOW THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BE AND
REALLY I THINK VERY FUNDAMENTAL
IN TAKING OUT ON. AS WE'VE SEEN
PEOPLE TRANSITION- ITO NEW
CAREERS AND ESPECIALLY AFTER
THE PANDEMIC OF THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR RETRAINING AND HERE RE
ENTERING AND FOR VETERANS FOR
LAND FOR FOSTER KIDS SO LET ME
START WITH YOU MISS PERRY AND
THEN DOCTOR VIA LOBOS JUST GIVE
ME YOUR THOUGHTS ON WHETHER WE
WERE MEETING TARGETS ON THAT
WHOLE- COMPONENT OF WHAT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAVE TAKEN
ON HOW TO ACTUALLY PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRANSITION INTO.
NEW CAREERS IF THE ONE YOU HAD
LOST DIDN'T WORK OUT OR OR
WE'VE LOST- BASICALLY- AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR EMPLOYMENT AND
THEN AND NOW NOW WHAT YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT BECAUSE AND
THERE'S AN ISSUE REGARDING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND WHETHER
WE'RE MEETING THAT THE TARGETS
I GUESS BETTER SAID THE GOALS
THAT CERTAINLY UP. THAT YOU ALL
WOULD HAVE BEEN HOW DO YOU FEEL
ABOUT THE ON THE COLLEGES
HOUSEHOLDS ACROSS THE STATE
THAT ARE FOCUSING AND MEETING
SOME OF THE GOALS. THAT YOU
WOULD HOLD WOULD BE ATTAINED-
THANK YOU CENTER THANK YOU FOR
THE- I MEAN FROM A- THE- WE'VE
MADE GREAT STRIDES- THAT. THERE
HAS BEEN. AND TREMENDOUS
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
SERVICES AVAILABLE PLUS YOU CAN
EVEN RENAME SOME OF THE
PROGRAMS AND COUNTIES TO. DO
NEXT UP AND THERE'S BEEN AN
ONGOING RECOGNITION THAT THOSE
STUDENTS NEED BOTH- THE
ACADEMIC OPPORTUNITY BUT TO BE
BOLSTERED BY- SUPPORTS THAT
RECOGNIZED- THE PARTICULAR
HARDSHIPS THEY FACED IN THEIR
YOUNG LIVES SO. I THINK WE
PLAYED A GREAT FOUNDATION AS I
MENTIONED NEXT UP IS A FORTY
FIVE COLLEGES YOU KNOW WE HOPE
IT'LL BE A NINETY COLLEGES- IT.
AND IT CAN SERVE MORE AND MORE
USE THAN I THINK- SINCE WE HAVE
A POPULATION AS SIGNIFICANT
POPULATION OF PROPERTIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- CERTAINLY
WE NEED MORE SERVICES TO
SERVICE USE BUT WE HAVE. LAID
THE FOUNDATION AND WORKING DOWN
AND MOVING FORWARD- I SEE GREAT
PROMISE FARE- YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT- I
DO AGAIN THINK THAT WERE ON A
REALLY STRONG TRACK. MOVING TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THOSE I THINK
IT'S ABOUT A MILLION SORT OF
MID MIDDLE INCOME- HIGHER
HIGHER INCOME JOBS THAT WILL
BE- NEEDED TO BE FILLED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE NEXT
FIVE OR SO YEARS. AND WHAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING FROM WORK
FORCE DEVELOPMENT STANDPOINT-
AND FOCUSING A LOT ON-
HEALTHCARE AND HOSPITALITY
ISSUES BUT CREATING THE
CONSORTIUM COLLEGES AND
EMPLOYERS AND SEVEN DISTRICTS
LOOKING TO CREATE AN ACTUAL
QUITE WANT TRY BLIND IT WILL
TRAIN THE STUDENTS. IN A TRADE
THAT MATCHES THE EMPLOYERS NEED
AND YOU'RE SEEING A LOT OF
SUCCESS IN THAT AREA YOU'RE
SEEING STUDENTS- IT'S ON THE
COLLEGES THAT ARE- BEING
ENTERED INTO JOBS THAT ARE
PAYING. 9% AND MORE OF WHAT
THEY PREVIOUSLY EARNED- AND
YOU'RE SEEING THEM. ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF IT HELP THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. MY FEELING THAT.
NIELSEN NEED TO BE FILLED
CORPORATE TYPE OF JOBS- I THINK
WE'VE GOT. FIVE THOUSAND
COMPLETIONS THAT AREA AGAIN
AGAIN REALLY GOOD START THERE
SO MUCH MORE WE CAN DO BUT I DO
SEE A LOT OF PROMISE. IN THE
WORK FORCE DEVELOPMENT AREA.
THANK YOU. INDUCTOR WILL BMO
BOTH YOUR THOUGHTS FOR VETERANS
ON THAT. WHAT WE AND- FIRST AND
FOREMOST FACT THAT I DON'T LOVE
UNITY COLLEGES THAT THE STATE-
I CAN TELL YOU- SETTLE BACK IS
IT GOING ON AMAZING JOBS- ALONG
WITH OUR- OTHERS BUT FELL BACK
IT'S NOT AN AMAZING JOB CERTAIN
THE BECKHAM POPULATION- I WANT
TO BE PACKED A LOT OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. HAVE NOT VISITED YET-
BY. FOR PERSONAL. WORKING WITH
THAT WITH. BATTLE BACK AND
NOVEMBER INDIVIDUALS COLUMBUS
DAY COLLEGE JOB READ- FIBER- IT
WOULD BE CALLING- I MEAN TO YOU
THAT ARE. RESOURCE CENTER ARE
YOU MADE JOB WITH A POPULATION
OF MAIL CARE- IT IS NOT
UNCOMMON FOR ME A CALL- THE
RESEARCH CENTERS YOU. HAVE
PARTNERSHIP WHERE IT LOOKED
WORKING. AND ALLOW THEM TO
PROVIDE A DISH RESOURCE FOR
ABOUT AND SO TALKING ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH HOUSING
EMPLOYMENT RESOURCE- WE HAVE
BACKED SCREENING OUR- GRADUATE
WITH A TRADE AND THEY ARE A- TO
KEEP CONNECT WITH LOCAL. WE'RE
GONNA THAT COMPLY THEM. INTO A
JOB FOR TO PARTNER. IF I WOULD
BE- WERE ALSO TO- YOURS THAT
ARE. I DIDN'T FIND IT ME. RIGHT
THERE ARE. THAT PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FOR. AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR CONNECTED
WITH ALL THESE ORGANIZATIONS
YOU. ARE IN A PROACTIVE WAY
ENGAGE THE VETERAN POPULATION I
THINK YOU NEED A SERVICE THAT
THAT. THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
I'M VERY PROUD OF OUR COLLEGES-
BECAUSE IT TAKES A LOT OF EXTRA
WORK- THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT IS THE PHONE JOB
DESCRIPTION DOESN'T REALLY
LITERALLY SOMEONE TAKE IN
ADDITIONAL TIME OUT OF HIS
SCHEDULE. TO ENGAGE WITH LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND IDENTIFY THE
RESOURCES ARE VETERANS NEED AND
MAKE SURE THAT OUR PENSIONS GET
THOSE SOURCES. HAVING
ORGANIZATION AFTER THE CAMPUS
OFFENSE AND FIND EVERY EVERY
WEEK LIKE THEY DO I SETTLE BACK
FOR EXAMPLE. AND BE AVAILABLE
FOR VETERANS AND MILITARY
FAMILIES THOSE RESOURCES. HI IT
IS GIVEN OUT THAT KIND. OF
ALONG WITH THE GI BILL THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. ATTEND A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND- AND-
WHAT YOUR SCHOOLS AND- GRADUATE
AND FIND OUT OF PRINT-
SECONDARY IN THE WORK FORCE
SITE- EMPLOYMENT HAS BEEN- A
BIG CHALLENGE AND- WELL I WORK
FOR THE CITY OF LA WE HAVE
THAT. INVOLVEMENT STRONG
INITIATIVE AND OUR GOAL WAS TO
GET TEN THOUSAND LIKES THE FACT
WORKING. WE'RE ABLE. TO DIGITAL
JOB SO- HONESTLY AND THAT THE
WORK THAT OUR OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WE ARE SEEING- DOING IT
IT'S AMAZING- HI I REALLY
APPLAUD THE WORK FACT CAIRNS
AND STEAM- ARGUING THAT SETTLE
BACK. I AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN
REPLICATE THAT BLEW UP. OUR
SYSTEM. THANK YOU THOSE FANS
SAYS. AND ARE YOU WILL BOTH
HAVE OF MY STRONG SUPPORT TO
CANADA. AGAIN YOU'RE SO LUCKY
TO BE SERVING ON THIS BOARD FOR
SUCH A GREAT- AGENCY ACROSS OUR
STATE THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES BY
THE WAY I DID GET THOSE EXTRA
UNITS AT LONG BEACH CITY
COLLEGE. SO ANYWAY I TAKE CARE
AND- THANKS AGAIN FOR YOUR
SERVICE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR SENATOR GROWTH.
THANK YOU MADAM FOR TEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE- TOOK ME
COLLEGE BOARD AND- MISTER VILLA
LOBOS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY AND
ABSOLUTELY. I DID HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE SAME
QUESTIONS THAT TIME MY
COLLEAGUES ANSWER ASKED- SO
I'LL ASK A DIFFERENT ONE. IN A
RECENTLY THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
NEWS ESPECIALLY IN CALMATTERS
REGARDING- WHAT'S ASSUMING OF
PETITIONS FOR SCHOOL AND
COLLEGE CLASSES. AND APPLYING
FOR GRANTS AND THE NEWS
ARTICLES GOES ON THAT AFTER
THIS PARTICULAR INCIDENT WAS
BROUGHT UP BY A PROFESSOR. TO
THE ORGANIZATION AND THEY
CHECKED- DID THE BACKGROUND OR
DID SOME INVESTIGATING THEY
FOUND OUT THAT THEY WERE
HUNDRED SIXTEEN COLLEGE SYSTEMS
THAT SAY THERE HAD A SPIKE IN
CYBER ATTACKS. THE BOATS WERE
FEELING AT CLASSES AND TAKEN
SLOTS FROM REAL STUDENTS IT
TERM SEEM TO BE WELL
ORCHESTRATED AND A AND A LITTLE
COOLEY LED THE ASSAULT OF
WEAKNESS IN THE SYSTEM. IT'S A
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS WERE TAKEN FROM
ONE. CALIFORNIA STATE AID
COMMISSION THEY APPEAR TO BE
FAKE THERE WERE OTHERS WHERE-
SEVENTY THOUSAND FROM ANOTHER
COLLEGE WERE TARGETED CONTRA
COSTA FIVE HUNDRED ACCOUNTS
DEEMED TO BE FAKE SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND. FROM THE EXECUTIVE
DEAN OF INSTITUTIONAL
EFFECTIVENESS EFFECTIVENESS AT
SENIOR CENTER COLLEGE IN
RIVERSIDE. THE ESTIMATED FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND FAKE
APPLICATIONS IN TWENTY TWENTY
FROM AND SISKIYOU COUNTY ONE
MILLION IN PELL GRANTS. IN THE
SUMMER IDENTIFYING SOME THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND FAKE STUDENT
ACCOUNTS WERE RESOURCES HAVE
BEEN. ALLOCATED TO THESE FAKE
STUDENTS ARE BOXES WHAT THEY'RE
CALLING HIM. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
WILL RECEIVE ABOUT FOUR POINT
THREE BILLION. DOLLARS- WE ONE
POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION. WILL
GO TO STILL- NUMBER WHEN WERE
YOU GUYS AWARE OF THIS AND
NUMBER TWO CAN YOU TELL US WHAT
YOU'RE DOING TO COMBAT THIS
FRAUD OF TAXPAYERS MONEY. WE
HAVE A HUGE EDT SCANDAL WE
DON'T NEED A COMMUNITY COLLEGE-
GRANT SCANDAL. IF YOU WANT I
CAN START AND NOT PLASTIC YOU
WANT TO FILL IN- THANK YOU FOR-
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO BE WITH US EARLIER AND FOR
BRINGING UP THIS ISSUE BECAUSE
YES WE ARE WELL AWARE- OUR OUR
VICE CHANCELLOR. AT ACTING-
CHANCELLOR SKEWS ME GONZALEZ-
BROUGHT THIS TO OUR ATTENTION
IMMEDIATELY- AND STARTED
OUTLINED THE STEPS THAT SHE'S
TAKING ACROSS THE SYSTEM- TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE- WHICH
OBVIOUSLY NONE OF US WANT TO
HAVE. HAPPEN AND- WE NEED TO
ADDRESS IT NOW AND STRONGLY AND
FIRMLY- SHE'S ALREADY WORKING
WITH- THE INSPECTOR GENERAL OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF THE FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION- THEY
ARE. LOOKING AT NEW DATA
REPORTING- FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ON UP LOOKING AT
MODERNIZING OUR- CCC APPLY
SYSTEM TAKING IMMEDIATE AND
STRONG STEPS TO ADDRESS AND
ROOT OUT THIS FRAUD BECAUSE
YOU'RE RIGHT NO ONE WANTS THEIR
TAX DOLLARS. GOING TOWARD
ANYTHING OTHER THAN THE
STUDENTS FOR- FOR WHOM THERE
ARE A LOT IT SO THAT THE BOARD
OF GOVERNORS HAVE BEEN MADE
VERY AWARE OF THIS AND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE WILL HAVE A-
LENGTHY AND IN DEPTH
PRESENTATION AT OUR- UPCOMING
MEETING- SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO. TO LOOK AT THIS AS
A LOOK AT THIS PROBLEM AND MAKE
SURE IT IS AT. ADEQUATELY.
ADDRESSED THANK YOU. MR VIA
LOBOS YOU HAVE A TO ADD. YES
AND- FOR MOST BETTER GROWTH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
WHILE- AS- MEMBER MENTIONED-
IT'S- AN ITEM OF THE UP
IMPORTANCE- HAVING WORKED IN
THE NONPROFIT SECTOR FOR SO
MANY YEARS I CAN TELL YOU THAT.
NO ONE WANTS TO SEE AN ALERT
ANY OF OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE
GOING AWAY- ESPECIALLY IN A
BROADWAY- I AM- RIGHT THERE
WITH- MEMBER CARRYING ON HER
KIND OF COMING- I KNOW THAT
YEAH CHAPLET BOPPARD-
MONITORING THE SITUATION AND-
YOU HAVE WHILE- AND WE HOPE TO
GET TO. THE BOTTOM OF IT AND-
YOU KNOW ADDRESS IT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE GETTING INYO AND- MOST PART
IN THE NATURE THAT OUR STUDENTS
ARE NOT IMPACTED BY. WELL THE
YOU VERY MANAGE AM I IT'S COME.
IN YOUR EYES CAN BOTH- YOU AND
MY PERRY. IT'S NOT COMPLETE IN
YOUR- BUT WOULD YOU- SUPPORT AN
AUDIT IN THIS- TO DO A COMPLETE
INVESTIGATION SO THAT WE COULD
ACTUALLY FIND OUT IF THERE IS.
A FRAUD TAKING PLACE AND- I
MEAN WE OBVIOUSLY KNOW THERE'S
FRAUD TAKING PLACE BUT THAT
WE'VE BEEN COVERED IN. LOSS OF
DOLLARS AND HOW WE CONDEMN THE
INDEPENDENT AUDITOR COULD
POSSIBLY MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO PREVENT THIS FRAUD FROM
HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE. I
THINK CENTER THAT'S AN
EXCELLENT QUESTION I WOULD HAVE
TO SAY THIS IS SO NEW- IT WOULD
BE OUT OF MY PURVIEW TO COMMENT
ON WHETHER THEY SHOULD BE IN ON
IT I THINK YOU KNOW GIVE US A
MONTH OR SO TO REALLY FULLY. OR
A COUPLE OF MONTHS TO REALLY
LOOK AT THIS AND DIGEST AND
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING SO. I THINK IT WOULD
BE PREMATURE FOR ME- IN TERMS
OF WHERE WE ARE IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING THE CHALLENGE AND
ALSO- TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION
IN THE AFFIRMATIVE OR THE
NEGATIVE AT THIS JUNCTURE- AND
ALSO LET ME TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY. TO- TELL NUMBER
AVAILABLE VIA LOBOS AND I WERE
FOR DOING THAT WE- HEAR FROM
THE REMAINDER OF THE MEETING
APOLOGIES. WE'VE CONNECTED A
LOT THROUGH THIS PROCESS SO
APOLOGIES FOR THE INFORMALITY.
I DON'T THINK HE WOULD BUT HE
MINDS I THINK IT'S AND- MORE
PERSONAL WE DO HAVE A AT A
PROTOCOL HERE TO. YOU KNOW.
MEMBER PERRY MEMBER AND- AS- AS-
THE LOBOS AND- I MEAN THERE'S
PEOPLE I MEAN THE OTHER DAY I
WAS CONSUMMATE GALA G. INTERNS
GALGIANI THAT I'VE ALWAYS COME
TO THE L. G. YOU KNOW SO IT'S-
IT'S JUST DIFFERENTLY AND IT
SHOWS CLOSENESS AND PERSONAL
PERSONALITY SO I WOULDN'T I
DON'T THINK I'D WORRY ABOUT IT
I'M NOT SPEAKING FOR YOU. MR
VILLALOBOS. YEAH HE DID. THE
MOST CERTAINLY AT- AS YOU WITH
THAT- WE NEED WITHOUT. HOT SO
THIS LAST MONTHS I'VE PREPARE
FOR THAT WHILE SO HAVE TO FOUND
RIGHT BELOW- DESPITE THAT AND
THAT THIS. AND NOT A LITTLE
PERSON BY. OUR AGREE WITH HER
ON HER- REGARDING- IT BEING
PERFECT PRICE. I GIVE YOU
RESPONSE RIGHT NOW- YEAH YOU
KNOW. TO FROM NOW WILL BE ABLE
TO ANSWER SITUATION AND WE'RE
COME BACK. TO YOU WITH A WORK.
ANSWER AND IT'S TOPIC. I
RESPECT THAT RISK AND I YOU
VERY MUCH FOR- MAKE. I SPENDING
TIME BOTH OF YOU THE OTHER DAY.
ESPECIALLY WITH YOUR- ON- I
BRING THIS ISSUE THAT I BROUGHT
IT PUBLICLY TODAY BECAUSE I
WASN'T AWARE ABOUT IT AND WE'RE
OF IT UNTIL THIS AFTERNOON OR
YESTERDAY ACTUALLY. SO THANK
YOU AND I LOOK FORWARD. TO YOUR
GUISES CONFIRMATION. OKAY THANK
YOU SENATOR WATER THANK YOU
MADAM TEM O. AS SOMEONE WHO
ONCE ON A- BOARD OF TRUSTEES
FOR OUR OTHER COMMUNITY.
DISTRICT I HAVE MUCH RESPECT
YOU BOTH- I BELIEVE YOU BOTH TO
BE ABLE TO QUALIFY FOR THESE
APPOINTMENTS AND I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS SINCE MANY OF THE
QUESTIONS I WOULD HAVE ASKED.
HAVE ALREADY BEEN POSED TO YOU
SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR- AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE- THEN AS NOW. I'M I
THINK- AS I ONLY HAVE ONE
QUESTION I. LIKE MY COLLEAGUES
REALLY RESPECT THE SYSTEM FEEL
LIKE WE HAVE SOME EXCELLENT
EXAMPLES OF MY OWN COMMUNITY IN
SAN DIEGO. OF FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM. IT IS
A VERY LARGE SYSTEM WITH OVER
TWO MILLION STUDENTS I BELIEVE
AND- IN TERMS OF THE
REPRESENTATION WE HAVE
OBVIOUSLY- URBAN AREAS LIKE THE
LOS ANGELES AREA THE BAY AREA
YOU KNOW SAN DIEGO WHILE WE
HAVE EIGHT OR NINE- IT'S STILL
SMALLER THAN THAT AND I THINK
THE BAY AREA AS A WHOLE AND LOS
ANGELES. BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THROUGHOUT
THE REST OF THE STATE- AND
OTHER COUNTY SO I GUESS I WOULD
ASK YOU TO INDULGE ME AND HELP
ME. UNDERSTAND YOUR PERSPECTIVE
AS YOU APPROACH THE WHOLE
SYSTEM. AND WHAT THE NEEDS OF
SOME OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE AND MAYBE SOME OF OUR MORE
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND COUNTIES
VERSUS SAY ARE LARGER URBAN
AREAS. AND AS A IT ARE THE
CERTAINLY A GOVERNOR ON THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS. YOU KNOW
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU LOOK AT
THAT JUST AT IT'S NOT A DIRECT
SPECIFIC QUESTION BUT IT'S MORE
WHAT'S YOUR PHILOSOPHY ON.
REPRESENTATION FOR AREAS
BROADER THAN AREAS YOU MIGHT
REPRESENT FOR THE WHOLE SYSTEM
SO MISS PERRY I'LL START WITH
YOU AND THEN- I GO TO DOCTOR
VIA LOBOS- THANK YOU CENTER AND
I ACTUALLY THINK ONE OF THE-
STRENGTHS OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM IS EXACTLY THAT.
IT'S EXTRAORDINARY BREADTH AND
DIVERSITY NO ONE COLLEGE IS
EXACTLY LIKE THE OTHER YOU KNOW
WITHIN LA YOU HAVE A COLLEGE
THAT HAS A GREAT AERONAUTICS
PROGRAM- YEAH AND YOU KNOW. IT
IN THE VALUE OF ONE THAT HAS A
PROGRAM IT'S WORKING WITH TESTS
ON CARS IN THE MORE RURAL AREAS
THAT EACH. WHAT'S BEEN REALLY
WONDERFUL ABOUT THE WAY THE
SYSTEM WORKS AND SOMETIMES
CHALLENGING BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN- PHYSICAL
ENTITIES THAT ARE SERVING VERY
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES IN VERY
DIFFERENT NEEDS BUT- THE WAY
THE SYSTEM IS STRUCTURED. IT
DOES TO A LARGE DEGREE IN ABLE
EACH COLLEGE TO DEVELOP. THE
PLANS AND SERVICES THAT. THAT
SERVE THE SPECIFIC COMMUNITY IN
WHICH THEY SET AND I THINK THAT
IS A REAL STRENGTH- AND SO EACH
ONE OF THEM HAS A BLUEPRINT
THAT LOOKS. DIFFERENT AND EACH
THAT SERVICE. DIFFERENT NEEDS
AND SO I THINK THAT STRENGTHENS
THE SYSTEM OVERALL IT MAY. ON
OCCASION- POST SOME GOVERNANCE
CHALLENGES BUT- I THINK WE
FIGURED OUT. HOW TO- WORK WITH
ALL OF THE COLLEGES AND IN IN A
POSITIVE WAY- AND AGAIN. YOU
KNOW I SEE I'VE SEEN FOR MY
VISITS TO THE COLLEGES IN LA.
AGAIN EACH ONE HAS A DIFFERENT
STRENGTH THERE'S AN
EXTRAORDINARY CULINARY PROGRAM
AT ONE. THERE IS- AN
EXTRAORDINARY NURSING PROGRAM
IN ANOTHER- SO EACH ONE IS. IS
RESPONSIVE AND- AND- RESPONSIVE
TO THE NEEDS OF THE KIDS
COMMUNITY IN WHICH THEY SET.
THANK YOU DOCTOR VIA LOBOS.
WHAT WE AND I WOULD SAY THAT-
AS IT MOVES TO YOUR BACKGROUND-
YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY MANY OF
THE ISSUES THAT ARE VETERANS
GENERAL VETERAN POPULATION OUR
STUDENTS ACTIONS ARE BOB SO ANY
CHALLENGES- IN THE RURAL AREAS
ARE QUESTIONS FACING- ANY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE- WITH OUR
STUDENT VETERANS IN RURAL AREAS
FOR BASED ON THE SAME
CHALLENGES. WELL WE HAVE SEEN
IN THE LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS
HOWEVER IS THAT- MANY OF OUR
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO TRANSITION FROM AN
IN PERSON SERVICE MODEL GOING
ONLINE SERVICE MODEL WHICH HAS
ALLOWED- FOURTEEN MANY OF THESE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SECOND
RESOURCE CENTERS WILL REACH OUT
TO THAT ORGANIZATION THAT CAN
PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR OUR
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES. IN
THIS REPLIES FEDERAL
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL WE ARE
SEEING- AN INCREDIBLE- NUMBER
OF ACTION FOR CIVIL SERVICES IT
WOULD TELL HEALTH ARE IF
ANYTHING I WOULD SAY YOU KNOW
GIVEN THE LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS-
YOU KNOW. IT I WOULD SAY. MAKE
A POSITIVE I AM- OR THAT
HAPPENED THAT ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO UP AND READ
OUT TO THE THAT WE KNOW NOT BE
TO SERVICE GET TO THE DISTANCE
ARE FROM THERE THERE ARE FROM
YOUR OFFICE OUR AND THEY'VE
BEEN TO PROVIDE BILLS ARE ON-
BUT IS PERRY MENTIONED-
EVERYTHING CALL THAT- YOU KNOW
I LIKE I SAID I YEARS OF SOME
OF THE- COLLEGE LIKE THIS IT-
ALL OF THEM A VERY. GOOD
FACTIONS THIS OR CENTER- BUT
ONE DIFFERENT AND EACH ONE OF I
RESOURCES ARE SERVICES THAT ARE
TO THE BETTER KNOWLEDGE AND
POPULOUS AND- AREA SO IT'S
ALWAYS OUT FASCINATING YOU GO
VISIT DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES.
AND TAKE A LOOK AT THE
DIFFERENT RESOURCES THEY OFFER
FOR THE VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES ARE BASED ON WHAT THE
LOCAL RESOURCES ARE AND OTHER
RESOURCES THAT. COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PROVIDE. THANK I. TO
SNOW THE MORE THE- EITHER A
HUNDRED SIXTY IF NOT A FEW
COMMUTER KERR. IN A- BOARD OF
GOVERNORS- IT'S A VERY
DIFFERENT ANIMAL THAN SAY CSU
OR UC. AND SO THE WHOLE ISSUE
AND DISCUSSION OF GOVERNANCE
HAS TO BE. LOOKED AT PROBABLY
VERY DIFFERENTLY SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. I
THINK NOW WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND MOVE TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AND WE ARE GOING TO
START WITH MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WANT TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. AND BEFORE I START
RIGHT HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE I'M GOOD A AS A
REMINDER FOR WITNESSES THAT
WANTED- COMMENT. VIA PHONE THAT
THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AGAIN IS. 877-226-8189.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE EIGHT NINE. THE
ACCESS CODE IS. 287-605-9287
SIX ZERO FIVE NINE SO FOLKS
MIGHT WANT TO START T. AND UP
RIGHT NOW- I'M GONNA BEGIN
RIGHT HERE WITH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. OUR I ACTUALLY
DON'T SEE ANYONE HERE ARE. TO
TESTIFY PUBLICLY SO- WE ONLY
HAVE ONE ROOM TODAY NOT TO AS
IS TYPICAL WE HAVE OTHER
HEARINGS IN PROCESS SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE RIGHT ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE OUR SYSTEM AND
LET ME WELCOME OUR MODERATOR
FOR TODAY AND ASKED THE
MODERATOR TO PROP INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU YOU DO WISH TO. SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS AT THIS TIME
YOU MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO USING YOUR TELEPHONE AGAIN
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
THREE. AND AS WE WAIT ON-
PEOPLE TO T. R. I'M GOING TO
REMIND WITNESSES THAT WHEN YOU
SPEAK. PLEASE PROVIDE YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION IF ANY THE
POSITION ON THE APPOINTMENT AND
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF OUR COURT
REPORTER PLEASE SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY. MISTER MODERATOR
GOING BACK TO YOU. THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO LINES IN
Q. OKAY WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I LET ME THEN COME BACK
INTO THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I
ACTUALLY STILL SEE NO ONE HERE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
THAT WOULD BE IN OPPOSITION SO
AREN'T MISTER MODEATOR I'M
GONNA COME BACK TO YOU HOPE IN
PEOPLE REMEMBER THE NUMBER IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE EIGHT NINE. THE
ACCESS CODE IS. TWO EIGHT SEVEN
SIX ZERO FIVE NINE BACK TO YOU
MISTER MODERATOR. OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THIS SPEAKING. TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME YOU MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO USING YOUR TELEPHONE.
AS ONE BEEN. ZERO WE HAVE NO
LINES IN Q. MISTER MODERATOR
THANK YOU YOUR JOB WAS PRETTY
EASY TODAY- BUT I GUARANTEE YOU
THAT MAY NOT BE TRUE GOING
FORWARD SO I THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US TODAY AND
PREPARED TO HELP. I IN TWO TO
THE GOVERNOR'S IN WAITING LET
ME JUST SAY THAT'S A VERY GOOD
SIGN FRANKLY BECAUSE PEOPLE DO
CALL WHEN THEY HAVE OPINIONS
SO- THAT OBVIOUSLY SPEAKS TO-
TO THE FACT THAT YOU ARE. AIR
TO READY TO GET BACK TO WORK ON
THIS AND WITH THAT I AM SEEIN
THAT SENATOR LAYERED HAS LIGHT
AND MIKE ON AND READY TO GO I
WOULD MOVE THE CONFIRMATION OF
BOTH THESE CANDIDATES. AND
SEEING THAT PEOPLE ARE FINE
WITH THOSE NOMINEES BEING TAKEN
TOGETHER LET ME ASK MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ROVE HI ROBERT HI KAMLAGER I.
MARGARET I LAYERED ARE LAYERED
I EIGHT I BATES AYE ATKINS I
HAVE BEEN FIVE FIVE ZERO THAT
IS FIVE TWO ZERO UNANIMOUS THIS
WILL MOVE ONTO THE SENATE FLOOR
FOR CONFIRMATION LET ME
CONGRATULATE BOTH OF YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
WATCH THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR CAN DO IT GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE WONDERFUL HAVE A GREAT
REST OF YOUR DAY OUT MADAM
SECRETARY WE HAVE ONE ITEM-
OPENED- AND THAT IS- THE SUB
COMMITTEE RATIFICATION FOR
CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE OUR CALL
THE ROLL EIGHT ALL RIGHT EIGHT
FIVE FIVE TWO ZERO THANK YOU
THAT IS FIVE TWO ZERO AND WE
WILL NOW ARE I THOUGHT LET ME
THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
ASSISTANCE AND PATIENCE TODAY.
I INTO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS ARE.
WE DIDN'T HAVE ANYONE
PARTICIPATE- PUBLICLY TODAY BUT
IF YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO AND YOU
WANT TO. YOU STILL MAY SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
VISIT OUR WEBSITE FOR
INSTRUCTIONS AGAIN YOUR
COMMENTS AND YOUR SUGGESTIONS
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT TO US WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOUR
TESTIMONY IS INCLUDED IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. SO
WITH THAT I THANK EVERYONE THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES WILL
NOW MOVE TO EXECUTIVE SESSION.